hi I'm Greg and I am an woods
I had a housewarming party the other day
and and just randomly showed up never
met her before she had no connection or
friends to the party sure like this
knocked on the door and I was like I
hear a party here and then she she
became like one of the highlights of the
night absolutely I did so I said and you
go oh okay no I do amber amber was on
the channel recently as a friend of and
and then Anne came to the party and I
was really cool we got the talking big
lover of film she's really talented
actress and I said dad you got to come
on the channel and I said yes I do
yeah we were both really drunk playing
spin the bottle
you know what's yawn all night she could
follow her at ages and would Instagram
is @bn would any connection to the gym
no not for the same people asking all
the time my last name I bet yeah yeah
you know Keanu Alba yeah I really want
to be everything everything trailer but
this totally sounds like my kind of
movie obviously everything is did you
like everything like everything yeah
this is my whole world my nurse my mom
my sickness I'm 18 and I've never been
outside if I did I would probably die
[Music]
I'm all for the bump welcome to the
neighborhood is your daughter on
[Music]
HQ emails completely is good eatin you
really different than I thought you were
dancing sexy right back and if you went
outside probably spontaneous combustion
can't have episode terrorists outside
viruses and bacteria the oceans I've
never seen it's not for you to decide
what do you mean you have to go shittily
friends people CDC it is why I know
things have to be alive but this isn't
living
oh she hurt oh man will you do oh that
is better you like respect you know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm willing to sacrifice everything just
to list one perfect day normally I don't
like those kind of like kind of no team
feels a little young adult yeah normally
I'm just like how this looks so silly
she and while it has a silly cheesy
elements to it I'd rather touched by
that you know I got some goose bumps
yeah and have you seen uh there's like a
John Travolta movie huh years ago about
like how we have to live in a plastic
bubble does exactly yeah there's so many
metaphors to this in some level even
though it is kind of like a young adult
smelling kind of thing with whatever
bubble you keep yourself in it's like
whatever you feel like is actually
what's going to make you feel alive and
yeah the person you want to be and go on
the adventure yes I hear conferences
yeah step outside your your step outside
of your bubble to explore it the only
way you can grow is by except now your
comfort zone experience being like the
main girl you know what there's a
website out there anarchic herder they
called him to buzz in the bus yeah and
above oh I get it
forget it yet the joke's on me is this
her mana Steinberg she doesn't look like
a Steinberg
no one Jewish I don't know what her
diseases me either I didn't quite
understand what the rules of the
universe here yeah removing his rule
yeah because when he was like stepping
into her home and like strangers are
coming in away she even allowed to have
that and I thought that because at first
I thought about that she couldn't go
outside because of the sunlight and then
I saw so many like one
yeah because it does seem like she just
sort of under house arrest
yeah I like her disease is not clearly
defined here right so maybe that's just
in the trailer yeah I mean it's Oxygen's
didn't sure this all went on where the
air is being filtered out and now I just
gotta see this monitor she died yeah
okay so Arnie are taken away in an
ambulance oh yeah well with the walk
moment I've been in the situation yeah
I'm that guy yeah you're that guy yeah
awesomely big women who are is like no
one's really chasing them I come along
oh you're like perfect the perfect
compromise right I'll settle for you
yeah okay yeah like no one's really
interesting to me because I'm sick
hahaha
but hey caring like you're desperate
Greg well alright this is how I talk
myself up to make myself more attractive
the only one who didn't seem all that
layered and while I'm sure we'll get
more layers of her in the movie was a
mom yeah I just didn't quite get why she
wouldn't even let the boy come by or
color I'm trying to see it from her
point of view right now right as the
protective mother as the other taker
like all these years that she spent
protecting her daughter I didn't think
like she's adding to the sheltered
environment and so if the boy just want
to at least come over right let him come
over yeah because she needs a social
life and if a boy have a shower
freshener who happens to live right next
door yeah yeah let them [ __ ] in yeah
yeah like let her have a maybe she's
worried they don't like break her heart
because not many guys would be willing
to being if it's a long haul especially
at such a young age probably I want to
go to college and explore his life and
not just see the girl who has to stay
home on deck exactly I could actually
understand what
from yeah yes yeah yeah yeah you know
you talk to my own ways all right cool
main actor looks great I'm a mom I'm
understanding for reasoning now yes yeah
I just like I do like the story that's
where I got the goose bumps I was like
yeah it's going down the path is
obviously going to go there we should I
got to get out of here but what she was
doing it I'm like that it's a great
blessed life lesson cuz I'm like
thinking I'm not sick
I should go out more right now like well
man I don't have those restrictions I
can break through my own yeah the only
restriction we have is up here all the
actions of our students is that we saw a
scene very excitin concise and everyone
seemed to have the same exact focus in
the film Shirley's in the trailer
everyone seemed to be quite on the same
page telling the same story I think it
seems very interesting to us I don't
know what like if this movie has any
reviews of it release already but I know
this trailer could have been
significantly more cheesy and it didn't
yeah yeah so yes kudos to the trailer
editor yeah
really says yeah yeah oh yeah but
showing the acting and stuff I'm like
this it doesn't like that yeah and yeah
cause it doesn't seem like TV acting I
felt like they were going for like a
good sense of realism here where was it
because I'm a most the time you see
desaturated especially in the opening
where she's monologuing about her life
I'm like oh these we gotta go right
around this yeah especially for first oh
and this was requested by Victoria's a
tour the tour one of the few female
people who actually watches our videos
yeah drivings of it yeah Victoria
congratulations you've gotten a shout
out from Greg you did it and and you're
so lucky you're so look this is the best
moment of your life oh you're light I'm
excited acharya go out there live your
life
yeah out of your bubble sleep with a
neighbor hahaha do to make yourself
happy
I mean I thought you went a little
gung-ho would you like to get in my life
and she goes outside it's traveling on a
plane whatever you're a girl
don't don't bend yes let me see too many
chances climate changes and everything
and I just went over the entryway two
days ha ha ha got your step-by-step
anyway you get subscribe to the real
rejects voila oh yeah I have a note here
it says to click that bell there's a
notification bell and you click it and
you know so there's time one of our
videos is up I just did that on your
channel you didn't you click the bell
after then I sure did I sure did what's
that thing I want to know whenever real
reject videos up at what is at God and
would Twitter ideal yeah the same thing
the endless or the the endless have to
be is pH all people are like what so
I've learned to see the inner what I can
change
yeah this is endless you couldn't
confuse me when there's a text here
right now at the bottom this train
you're gonna say yeah I put on Instagram
or the same as talking about having
videos up on YouTube and then so keep a
look at it watch you subscribe to her
channel it'll be done
yes and that is the magic miss and was
Miss Anne woods yet take care Trump
America